[Music]  I'm watching you you don't have to  remember hasta manana  it wasn't human he's a known terrorist  and he killed again  they didn't just kill them hacked into  their mind  is everywhere and the more I will find  him and I will kill him  [Music]  you never talk about your past not  remember the fragment there was an  attack you were dying we saved you and  now you say the others  everything they told you was a lie you  had a family  remember that but I was doing  [Music]  all you want for me  they did not save your life these  dollars  how many were there before me  she was the cook to have a creamy brain  i order you to terminate  thank you  they created me but they cannot control  me  you  you